also sie sehen frau bundeskanzlerin das
interesse ist riesengroß in dieses
besonders großer dem was sie jetzt uns
zu sagen habe ich darf sie bitten das
wort zu ergreifen
sehr geehrte präsidenten kollegen
kolleginnen und kollegen aus den
parlamenten lieber herr ischinger meine
damen und herren und natürlich grüße ich
auch den ministerpräsidenten des
freistaates bayern ich glaube münchen
ist eine tolle gastgeber stadt und die
kraft bayern zeigt sich hier in einer
ganz besonderen weise
wir haben noch andere schöne städte in
deutschland aber heute steht münchen ins
zentrum
meine damen und herren 2009 10 ist ein
jahr in dem denken wir daran dass vor
250 jahren alexander von humboldt
geboren wurde alexander von humboldt
lebte an der schwelle zur
industrialisierung und er war ein
wissenschaftler und reisender der
durchdrungen war von dem drang die welt
als ganzes zu verstehen und zu sehen
und er hatte mit diesem wunsch auch
ziemlich viel erfolg und sein credo wie
wir es in seinem mexikanischen
reisebüchern nachlesen können aus dem
jahr 1803 heißt alles ist wechselwirken
und ungefähr 200 jahre später im jahre
2000 hat der chemie nobelpreisträger
paul crutzen festgestellt nachdem er das
ozonloch und die chemischen
wechselwirkungen erforschte dass wir nun
in ein neues geologisches zeitalter
eintreten eiszeit und zwischen eiszeit
sind vorbei und wir haben das
anthropozän das dann 2016 wurde diese
definition auch von der internationalen
geologischen gesellschaft übernommen das
heißt wir leben in einem zeitalter in
dem die spuren des menschen so tief in
die erde eindringen dass auch
nachfolgende generationen dieses als ein
ganzes zeitalter
das vom menschen geschaffen wurde sehen
werden und das sind spuren von
kernwaffentests des
bevölkerungswachstums der
klimaveränderung der rohstoffausbeutung
der mikro plastik in den ozean und das
sind nur einige wenige stichworte von
dem was wir heutzutage tun
und all das hat auswirkungen auf die
globale sicherheit und auf die fragen
wie genau hier diskutiert werden
und deshalb ist es auch folgerichtig
wenn man sich einmal ankommt wo hat
diese tagung begonnen 1963 mit einer der
kunde tagung noch ganz geprägt von der
geschichte nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
und dem nationalsozialismus in
deutschland eine sehr transatlantische
veranstaltung deshalb freue ich mich
auch dass so viele vertreter der
vereinigten staaten von amerika heute da
sind hin zu einer umfassenden
sicherheitskonferenz heute von der bei
der man von energieversorgung über
entwicklungszusammenarbeit natürlich
verteidigungsfragen aber über einen ganz
umfassenden sicherheitsaspekt spricht
und das ist glaube ich genau die
richtige antwort wir müssen in
vernetzten strukturen denken die
militärische komponente da ist da war
eine und das was wir am anfang des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts ist jetzt
ja das zweite jahrzehnt des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts doch
spüren ist dass die strukturen in denen
wir arbeiten
im grunde immer noch strukturen sind die
aus den schrecknissen des zweiten
weltkriegs und des nationalsozialismus
entstanden sind
dass aber diese strukturen unglaublich
unter druck geraten weil die forderungen
und die entwicklungen erfordern dass sie
sich reformieren
aber ich glaube wir dürfen sie nicht
einfach zerschlagen und deshalb ist ja
das thema dieser sicherheitskonferenz
the great passen fangen jetzt mal nur in
dem ein teil an rivalität zwischen
großen mächten gibt uns ja schon einen
einblick dahin dass etwas was wir als
ganzes als eine architektur der welt
gesehen haben doch unter druck ist
und sogar hier als puzzle beschrieben
wird also als in teil i zu fall
vor 30 jahren daran werden wir dies sehr
denken fiel die berliner mauer und damit
auch der eiserne vorhang der kalte krieg
fand seinen abschluss
damals hat man darüber gesprochen
brauchen wir so etwas für die nato noch
und wir wissen heute ja wir brauchen die
nato als stabilitätsanker in stürmischen
zeiten
wir brauchen sie als wertegemeinschaft
denn wir sollten nie vergessen dass wir
die nato nicht nur als militärbündnis
gegründet haben sondern als eine
wertegemeinschaft in der menschenrechte
demokratie rechtsstaatlichkeit die
richtschnur für das gemeinsame handeln
sind und dass diese nato heute immer
noch über eine große attraktivität
verfügt das haben wir jetzt gesehen
in den letzten monaten als darum
gerungen wurde ob auch nord mazedonien
wie wir es jetzt glücklicherweise alle
gemeinsam nennen können mitglied der
nato werden kann und ich möchte einfach
den beiden hauptakteuren dem
premierminister sei es aus nord
mazedonien und alexis tsipras dem
griechischen ministerpräsidenten ganz
herzlich für ihren mut danken
die wir heute haben mit dem kleist preis
geehrt und es ist ein gutes beispiel bei
den vielen konflikten die wir haben wir
noch keine lösung gefunden haben das
immer mutig etwas in die hand nimmt man
doch auch lösungen finden kann
ich hatte es zwischenzeitlich schon
aufgegeben mir weitere namens
kombinationen zu überlegen weil ich
dachte es hat sowieso keinen sinn und
jetzt ist es gelungen und deshalb
wirklich großer glückwunsch
aber es gibt eben sehr viele konflikte
die uns herausfordern und das ist ja
auch der gegenstand der diskussion hier
und ich möchte mit einem beginnen der
mich auch sehr umtreibt in meiner
persönlichen arbeit aber viele von uns
auch das ist unser verhältnis zu
russland
russland war sozusagen ja mit in form
der sowjetunion der antagonist in zeiten
des kalten krieges und wir hatten ja
nach dem mauerfall durchaus hoffnungen
der zeit ist dann auch die russland nato
akte entstanden dass wir zu einem
besseren miteinander kommen könnten
und wenn ich mich jetzt noch mal
erinnere das im jahre 2011
hier am rande dieser
sicherheitskonferenz zwischen hillary
clinton und sergej lawrow die
ratifikationsurkunden für die für den
abrüstungsvertrag start ausgetauscht
wurden da erscheint ein das heute
2009/10 ziemlich lange her aber damals
haben beide von einem meilenstein in der
strategischen partnerschaft gesprochen
ich sage dass einerseits um zu zeigen
was in den letzten jahren passiert ist
andererseits aber auch zu sagen es kann
in ein paar jahren auch wieder ganz
anders aussehen wenn sich seiten
miteinander auch auseinandersetzen
deshalb möchte ich mich bei jens
stoltenberg ganz herzlich bedanken dass
er in den schwierigsten zeiten jetzt
auch die wir in den letzten jahren
hatten immer wieder auch auf der nato
russland akte nicht nur beharrt hat
sondern das gespräch gesucht hat recht
herzlichen dank dafür
in diesem jahr nun die nächste schlechte
kunde dann 2014 dann im märz der die
annexion der krim klares
völkerrechtswidrige essverhalten und
anschließend petro poroschenko ist hier
der angriff auf die austria
mühselig sozusagen fragil stabil
gehalten durch dieses minsk abkommen wo
deutschland und frankreich gemeinsam mit
russland und der ukraine versucht haben
den konflikt zu lösen allerdings müssen
wir sagen von der lösung sind wir weit
entfernt und wir müssen unbedingt
weiterarbeiten und für uns die europäer
wenn ich das so sagen darf in diesem
jahr die wirklich schlechte nachricht
der kündigung des vertrages nach
jahrzehnten nach jahrelangem muss man
nicht jahrzehnte aber jahrelang und
verletzungen durch russland dieser
vertragsbedingungen ist diese kündigung
unabwendbar gewesen wir haben sie alle
mitgetragen als europäer
trotzdem ist es noch mal das sagen
unseren amerikanischen kollegen eine
ganz interessante konstellation ein
vertrag der im grunde für europa
gefunden wurde
1 abrüstungsvertrag der unsere
sicherheit betrifft wird dann von den
vereinigten staaten von amerika und
russland in der rechtsnachfolge der
sowjetunion gekündigt und wir sitzen da
und werden natürlich mit unseren
elementaren interessen auch alles
versuchen um weitere abrüstungsschritte
möglich zu machen
denn die antwort kann jetzt nicht in
blindem aufrüsten liegen allerdings da
unser chinesischer vertreter ja heute
auch da ist würde ich sagen diese
abrüstung ist etwas was uns alle
umtreibt und wo wir uns natürlich auch
freuen würden wenn nicht nur zwischen
den vereinigten staaten von europa und
russland solche verhandlungen geführt
werden sondern auch mit china ich weiß
dass da viele vorbehalte gibt ja jetzt
auch nicht in die tiefe gehen aber
freuen
wir haben dann in antwort auf die
ereignisse in der ukraine von 2014/2015
in wales gesagt nicht nur der kampf
gegen den terrorismus wie wir sind
afghanistan gesehen haben sondern eben
auch die bündnisverteidigung steht
wieder ganz im mittelpunkt unserer
bemühungen und damals ist dann das ziel
die verteidigungsausgaben jedes landes
richtung 2% zu entwickeln auch wieder
aktualisiert worden
ich werde nicht müde darauf hinzuweisen
dass das schon anfang der 2000er 2000er
jahre ein ziel war
denn all die neuen mitgliedstaaten der
nato haben gleich als erstes gesagt
bekommen wenn ihr euch nicht in richtung
zwei prozent bewegt dann werdet ihr gar
nicht erst in die nato aufgenommen das
war noch vor meiner zeit als
bundeskanzlerin deutschland steht nun in
diesem zusammenhang in der kritik und
ich werde da im weiteren auch noch drauf
eingehen wir haben seit 2005 10 aber
immerhin unsere verteidigungsausgaben
von 118 prozent 2014 auf 135 prozent
gestärkt wollen 2024 bei 1,5 prozent
liegen
vielen reicht das nicht aber für uns ist
das ein existenten essentieller sprung
und natürlich müssen wir auch fragen was
tun wir denn mit dem geld und ich sags
mal so rum wenn wir alle in die
rezession verfallen und kein
wirtschaftswachstum haben dann wird das
mit den verteidigungsausgaben leichter
aber ob es dem bündnis dient das glaube
ich nicht
deshalb ist es glaube ich richtig dass
wir einerseits solche richtgrößen haben
aber andererseits auch überlegen was
sind die beiträge und ich glaube da
leistet deutschland seine beiträge wir
sind jetzt seit 18 jahren in afghanistan
und haben dort auch ungefähr 1300
deutsche soldatinnen und soldaten wir
sind zusammen mit 20 anderen im norden
afghanistans und ich habe eigentlich
einfach die sehr herzliche bitte das ist
ja der erste und einzige einsatz nach
artikel 5 der nato den wir doch sehr
gemeinsam jetzt über eine sehr lange
zeit durchführen
dass wir auch über die fragen der
fortentwicklung gemeinsam miteinander
sprechen denn sie haben viel
überzeugungsarbeit auch bei unserer
bevölkerung gebraucht um zu sein
ja unsere sicherheit wird am hindukusch
verteidigt und ich möchte wirklich nicht
erleben dass wir dann eines tages da
stehen und einfach weggehen müssen weil
wir natürlich sehr vernetzte kapazitäten
dort haben wir sind in litauen rahmen
nationen ich will das nicht alles
aufführen
wir haben zum zweiten mal die führung
bei der nato speerspitze übernommen also
dinge die gerade der bündnisverteidigung
sehr nutzen und insofern auch sind wir
bereit unseren beitrag zu leisten
wir sind inzwischen auch außerhalb der
nato in mali zum beispiel aktiv für
deutschland ein riesenschritt kulturell
nicht eingeübt wie zum beispiel unseren
französischen freunden und gerade diese
einsatz und die frage der entwicklung in
afrika und nicht umsonst hat er heute
morgen hier eine diskussion
stattgefunden zwischen dem präsidenten
der europäischen union der rotierenden
präsidentschaft und dem neuen
vorsitzenden der afrikanischen union im
ägyptischen präsidenten als cissé
herzlichen glückwunsch zu ihrer wahl das
war ja gerade erst vor wenigen tagen und
dieses verhältnis zu afrika zum beispiel
wird uns als europäer noch in anderer
weise fordern als zum beispiel die
vereinigten staaten von amerika da wird
es nicht immer nato einsätze geben und
deshalb bitte ich sie unsere bemühungen
und für eine kohärente europäische
verteidigungspolitik nicht als etwas zu
verstehen was gegen die nato gerichtet
ist sondern das als was zu verstehen was
die kooperation in der nato effizienter
und besser möglich macht weil viele der
ineffizienten die wir unter den vielen
mitgliedsstaaten die in der europäischen
union und in der nato sind wir
überwinden können wenn wir auch
gemeinsame militärische kultur
entwickeln wenn wir unsere waffensysteme
besser sortieren und ich sage ihnen da
wird für deutschland eine riesenaufgabe
vor uns stehen wir wollen jetzt
gemeinsam waffensysteme entwickeln und
im zusammenhang mit dem aachener vertrag
den wir jetzt mit frankreich
unterzeichnet haben hat natürlich das
thema rüstungsexporte eine rolle
gespielt denn werden wir keine
gemeinsame kultur der rüstungsexporte in
europa haben dann ist die entwicklung
von gemeinsamen waffensystemen natürlich
auch gefährdet das heißt man kann nicht
von einer europäischen armee sprechen
und von einer
gemeinsam rüstungspolitik oder rüstungs
entwicklung sprechen wenn man nicht
gleichzeitig dann auch bereit ist eine
gemeinsame rüstungsexportpolitik zu
machen und da haben wir in deutschland
noch viele komplizierte diskussionen vor
uns das ist glaube ich kein geheimnis
was ich ihnen hier gerade verrate damen
und herren neben dem verhältnis zu
russland haben wir den kampf gegen den
terrorismus als große herausforderung
und das was uns nach dem märz 2014
natürlich neben der euro-krise im
übrigen wir haben dann 2014/15 sehr
intensiv mit griechenland die
verhandlungen gehabt über den verbleib
in der eurozone
dann kam 2015 auf uns ganz massiv zu das
flüchtlingsthema das flüchtlingsthema
ist getrieben worden natürlich von der
situation in syrien das ja sozusagen ein
bürgerkrieg ist der dann gleichzeitig
noch aufgeladen wurde mit
terroristischen herausforderungen und
damit stand für uns eine sicherheits
aufgabe ganz anderer natur als die die
wir zum beispiel in zusammenhang mit der
bündnisverteidigung sehen
es stand nämlich die frage vor europa
sind wir auch bereit in gewisser weise
bei einem humanitären zivilisatorischen
drama verantwortung mit zu übernehmen
oder sind dir das nicht und dass so
viele flüchtlinge nach europa kamen hat
damit zu tun dass wir uns eben nicht
gekümmert haben vorher um die situation
der flüchtlinge in jordanien im libanon
dort in der türkei dort waren bereits
drei oder mehr millionen angekommen
die stabilität dieser länder war
wirklich gefährdet und das hat die
flüchtlinge dazu gebracht sich zum
schluss den schleppern und schleusern
anzuvertrauen und zu sagen wir suchen
uns andere wege und europa hat in diesem
zusammenhang dann eine aufgabe
übernommen und ja im übrigen nicht nur
deutschland zusagen aus schweden
österreich und anderen ländern
und wir haben damals in einer
humanitären notlage geholfen aber ich
glaube wir sind uns auch alle einig dass
die antwort auf humanitäre notlagen
zwischen staaten ich heißen kann dass
schlepper und schleuser das regime
übernehmen die flüchtlinge sich
unendlichen gefahren aussetzen sondern
es war die richtige antwort dass eu
türkei abkommen zu machen und es war die
richtige antwort für deutschland
auch seine entwicklungsausgaben zu
stärken und jetzt sagen haben wir in der
gleichen zeit in der zeit wo wir behält
hatten und jetzt in richtung zwei
prozent gehen in der innerhalb der nato
in ebenso großem umfang unserer
entwicklungskosten hochgefahren weil wir
gesagt haben auch das ist eine
sicherheitsfrage wenn wir jetzt nicht
endlich bezahlen und da sind wir einer
der größten geber auf der welt für die
humanitäre hilfe für die welthungerhilfe
für den un hat er damit es den menschen
dort besser geht dann wird sich dieses
flüchtlingsdrama perpetuieren und die
hilfsbereitschaft der deutschen zum
beispiel war damals großartig aber
trotzdem müssen wir die probleme vor ort
lösen und das ist das was wir jetzt
gerade lernen das war also eine
parallele herausforderung die ich
sicherheitspolitisch für genauso wichtig
wie die der verstärkten bündnisfähigkeit
und wir haben dann durch die situation
und dann kam dann durch die situation in
libyen ein vorgeschmack von dem auch in
richtung europa jetzt italien in diesem
falle bekommen von dem was sowieso im
raume steht nämlich der frage wie
entwickelt sich der afrikanische
kontinent weiter und die in fragilität
des staates in libyen hat dazu geführt
dass dieses libyen dann sozusagen
ausgangspunkt vieler afrikanischer
flüchtlingsbewegungen war
wobei unsere spanischen freunde ja schon
sehr viel früher zehn jahre 15 jahre
früher
diese herausforderungen vor sich hatten
in form von marokko und das hat die
europäische union dazu gebracht dass sie
sehr viel konsistenter sehr viel
entschiedener auch die partnerschaft mit
afrika entwickelt hat aber seien wir
ehrlich wir stehen immer noch am anfang
dieser partnerschaft denn wenn in
subsahara afrika aber auch in ägypten in
marokko in tunesien in algerien die
entwicklung nicht so verläuft dass junge
menschen die chance und die hoffnung
sehen dass sie in diesen ländern
lebensperspektiven haben dann werden wir
mit dem wohlstandsgefälle zwischen
europa und afrika nicht hinkommen und
wir sehen dass china in großer weise in
den vergangenen jahren bereits
entwicklungspolitik in afrika betrieben
hat im sinne von investitionen
wir sehen dass wir in europa sehr viel
klassische entwicklungspolitik betrieben
haben
ich habe mit präsident empfing sehr oft
darüber unterhalten wie kann man
eigentlich vielleicht auch voneinander
lernen was macht der eine gut was macht
der andere gut aber wir haben noch keine
entwicklungspolitische agenda erarbeitet
mit der wir sozusagen sagen können die
investitionen werden auch für
ausreichend arbeitsplätze reichen um
anschließend in diesen ländern
sicherheit und frieden und stabilität
auch haben
und wieder hat deutschland was uns gar
nicht so ins stammbuch unserer
geschichte geschrieben war in den zeiten
der bundesrepublik deutschland gesagt
okay wir unterstützen sowohl die g5 seil
truppe die versucht gegen terrorismus
anzugehen wir sind in mali und versuchen
dort auch mit den vereinten nationen
gegen den terror
muss vorzugehen wir sind in mali und
versuchen die streitkräfte auszubilden
aber gleichzeitig wird das alles nichts
nützen wenn diese länder keine
wirtschaftliche perspektive haben und
deshalb haben wir eben unsere
entwicklungshilfe erhöht aber ist auch
noch einmal die methodik dieser
entwicklungshilfe ist noch nicht so
ausgearbeitet und das können wir auch
nur mit der afrikanischen union zusammen
machen und ich bin sehr glücklich dass
die afrikanische union inzwischen klare
strategische vorstellungen hat afrika
2063 oder andere pläne mit denen afrika
sagt was es will denn es muss das was
man ja heutzutage fast in deutsch schon
auch als ownership bezeichnet es muss
sozusagen das eigene empfinden sein das
sind unsere programme und wenn
multilaterale zusammenarbeit in den
letzten jahren besser geworden ist muss
ich sagen ist die afrikanische union aus
meiner sicht dafür durchaus ein gutes
beispiel und meine damen und herren sind
das sozusagen die probleme die ihnen
darlegen wollte in denen deutschland
sich engagiert und jetzt geht es um die
frage der methodik unserer
zusammenarbeit denn wir haben natürlich
im transatlantischen bündnis sagen wir
mal es vom kern her ein
verteidigungsbündnis die außenminister
treffen sich zwar sehr häufig aber wir
haben viele jahre mit frankreich darüber
gesprochen darf man da auch politische
fragen diskutieren
meine these ist die nato wird ihren
aufgaben nur gerecht werden wenn sie
auch den vernetzten sicherheitsbegriff
immer wieder mit ins auge fasst und ich
glaube das geschieht ja auch in gewisser
weise denn allein militärisch können wir
ja keinen dieser vielen konflikte lösen
und da haben wir natürlich auch
spannungen in der frage wie sehen nun
die antworten aus wir sehen die
antworten aus richtung ukraine wir sind
einig mit dem minsker abkommen meine
herzliche bitte ist die sanktionen
gegenüber russland wenn es zu weiteren
verschärfungen kommt siehe soldaten
kehrt jetzt auch wirklich wieder
abgestimmt zu entwickeln wir haben
nichts davon wenn jeder seine eigenen
sanktionen entwickeln
dritter punkt ist wir stehen weiter zu
russland nato russland akte dass der
gesprächsfaden soll nicht weggehen und
dann haben wir den vierten punkt die
wirtschaftliche kooperation
darüber gibt es beispiele nord stream
zwei eine vielzahl von
diskussionen jetzt und ich verstehe
petro poroschenko der hier sitzt und
sagt ich bin 20 land für russisches
erdgas und ich möchte dass bleiben und
ich habe ihm immer und immer wieder
versichert dafür jede unterstützung zu
geben und die verhandlungen dafür zu
führen das wären bei wahlkampf hin oder
her auch weiter tun
zweitens ein russisches gas molekül
bleibt ein russisches gas molekül egal
ob es über die ukraine kommt oder ob es
über die ostsee co
das heißt die frage wie abhängig sind
wir von russischem gas
die kann durch die frage durch welche
pipeline das fließt nicht geklärt werden
und auch da sage ich ich bin bereit und
niemand will auch einseitig und völlig
einseitig von russland abhängig werden
aber wenn wir im kalten krieg als ich
noch auf der ddr seite saß uns sowieso
russe strafe bekommen habe aber auch die
alte bundesrepublik russisches gas in
hohem umfang eingeführt hat dann weiß
ich nicht warum die zeiten heute so viel
schlechter sein sollen dass wir nicht
sagen russland bleibt ein partner und
ich sag mal auch wieder in anwesenheit
es ist ja gar nicht so einfach links ist
poroschenko aus meiner perspektive
rechtsschutz der chinesische vertreter
ich sag mal wollen wir russland nur noch
in die abhängigkeit oder in die abnahme
von china bringen ist das unser
europäisches interesse finde ich auch
nicht wir wollen auch ein bisschen an
den handelsbeziehungen seiner lage ist
müssen wir darüber offen legen wir haben
uns jetzt strategisch entschieden obwohl
wir sehr viel denn die kapazität in
europa haben wir haben im grunde viel
mehr lng terminals als wir den tigers
haben angesichts der prognostizierten
verstärkung des gasverbrauchs aber auch
das lg der lg produktion gerade auch aus
den vereinigten staaten von amerika als
deutschland auch weiter auf allen sie zu
setzen und da wir aus der kernenergie
und aus der braunkohle und steinkohle
aussteigen ist deutschland ein sehr
sicherer absatzmarkt für egal für wen in
denen in den nächsten jahren was erdgas
angelangt dann haben wir das thema iran
was uns natürlich im augenblick spaltet
und wir müssen immer aufpassen dass
diese spaltung die mich sehr bedrückt
ich habe nicht in einer rede in der
knesset dazu verpflichtet dass die das
existenzrecht israels zur
staatsregierung deutschlands gehört und
das meine ich auch so wie es gesagt habe
und ich sehe die ballistische raketen
programm ich sehe den iran in jemen und
ich sehe vor allen dingen den iran in
syrien und die einzige frage die
zwischen uns steht den vereinigten
staaten von amerika und den europäern in
dieser frage ist
helfen wir der unserer gemeinsamen sache
unserem gemeinsamen ziel nämlich die
schädlichen oder die schwierigen
entwickelten wirkung des iran einzelnen
indem wir das einzige noch bestehende
abkommen auch kündigen oder helfen wir
der sache mehr in dem er den kleinen
anka den wir haben halten um daraus
vielleicht auf anderen gebieten auch
druck zu machen das ist die taktische
frage über die wir streiten aber die
ziele sind natürlich die gleichen aber
dann sage ich mal auch weil ich werde ja
auch hinter kritisiert ist es denn nun
ruht jetzt aus syrien sofort und schnell
abzuziehen vonseiten der amerikaner oder
ist es nicht auch wieder eine stärkung
der möglichkeiten ist iran und russlands
dort einfluss zu nehmen
auch darüber müssen wir sprechen
das sind die dinge die auf dem zu
schieben und die wir auch mit einem
und genau so ist es natürlich mit der
frage wie geht es weiter mit den
wirtschaftlichen beziehungen zwischen
china den vereinigten staaten und europa
riesenproblem die erleben china ist ein
aufstrebendes land wenn nicht in china
fahrer sagt china hier sagen die
chinesischen vertreter mir wir waren
1700 jahre von den 2000 jahren seit
christi geburt die führenden
wirtschaftsnationen und richtet euch
nicht auf es passiert weiter gar nichts
als dass wir wieder dahin kommen wo wir
immer waren ihr habt das noch nicht
erlebt in den letzten 300 jahre wir
sagen in den letzten 300 jahren waren
wir aber die führen erst die europäer
dann die vereinigten staaten von amerika
und wir zusammen und wir müssen halt mit
dieser situation umgehen und müssen
vernünftige lösungen finden damit daraus
nicht jetzt einen uns gegenseitig
schwächen der kampf wird und da sage ich
ganz offen ich unterstütze alle
bemühungen auch der fairness des handels
ich nenne das immer reziprozität darüber
müssen wir reden aber wir sollten es tun
im sinne der partnerschaft und der
tatsache dass wir noch so viele andere
probleme auf der welt zu lösen haben
dass es hilfreich wäre wir können uns
verständigen und ich setze ja in die
verhandlungen die mit die veilchen
staaten von amerika jetzt im
handelsbereich geführt werden große
hoffnung und ich sage ganz offen wenn es
uns erstes mit der transatlantischen
partnerschaft ist es zumindest nicht
ganz einfach für mich als deutsche
bundeskanzlerin jetzt zu lesen dass
offensichtlich ich habe es noch nicht so
schriftlich vor augen gehabt
offensichtlich das amerikanische
handelsministerium sagt deutsch
europäische autos sind eine bedrohung
der nationalen sicherheit der
vereinigten staaten von amerika schauen
sie wir sind stolz auf unsere autos das
dürfen wir auch um diese autos werden
gebaut in den vereinigten staaten von
amerika south carolina ist einer der
grössten denn dort ist das größte bmw
werk nicht in bayern in south carolina
und south carolina liefert wieder nach
china
und wenn jetzt diese autos die ja
dadurch dass sie in south carolina
gebaut werden doch nicht weniger
bedrohlich werden als dadurch dass sie
in bayern
werden plötzlich eine bedrohung der
nationalen sicherheit der vereinigten
staaten von amerika sind dann erschreckt
uns das und dann sage ich mir
und dann sorgen
dann sage ich einfach nur ich glaube es
wäre gut wir kommen ordentliche
gespräche miteinander immer wenn einer
etwas vorzubringen hat muss man darüber
reden das ist auf der welt so und dann
werden wir auch lösungen können
all diese fragen der brüssel artig auf
uns zukommen die hier ja auch gar nicht
alle nennen kann alle diese fragen sind
letztlich ausdruck einer grundfrage weil
wir merken wie der druck groß ist auf
unsere klassische für uns gewohnte
ordnung ist jetzt die frage fallen wir
in lauta puzzlesteine auseinander und
denken jeder kann für sich alleine das
problem am allerbesten lösen
und da kann man als deutsche
bundeskanzlerin über sagen da sind die
chancen für uns schlecht denn die
vereinigten staaten von amerika sind
wirtschaftlich so viel macht verlag der
dollar als währung ist soviel
machtvoller dass ich nur sagen kann na
klar dann sind da die besseren karten
und china ist so viel größer mit 1,3
milliarden einwohnern werden dennoch so
fleißig noch so tolle noch so super
senke mit 80 millionen werden wir nicht
dagegen ankommen wenn china sich
entscheidet mit deutschland will man
keine guten beziehungen wir haben und so
wird sich das überall auf der welt
abspielen und das ist die eine große
frage
bleiben wir bei dem prinzip dass die
lehre aus dem zweiten weltkrieg unter
die mit dem von deutschland wär
verursacht nationalsozialismus war das
ist multilateral nicht toll ist
schwierig ist langsam ist kompliziert
ist aber dass sich in die schuhe des
anderen zu versetzen einmal über den
eigenen tellerrand zu gucken und
zuschauen kriege ich gemeinsame wohin
win lösungen
nach meiner festen überzeugung besser
ist als die meinung alle dinge alleine
lösen zu können und deshalb
und jetzt also den damen und herren war
ich gestern abend so glücklich als ich
mich nochmal auf meine rede vorbereitet
habe dass ich ein zitat von lancy ge
lindsay graham gelesen habe der gestern
abend gerufen hat multilateralismus mag
kompliziert sein aber er ist besser als
alleine zu hause zu sein und ich finde
genau das ist die antwort auf dieses
motto dieser tage the great puzzle hubl
picked up to pick up the pieces nur wir
alle zusammen
herzlichen dank
[Musik]
na ja wir können vielen dank frau
bundeskanzlerin bei dieser demonstration
des applaus ist kann man sich die frage
stellen gibt es noch fragen
aber ich vermute es gibt welche und ich
hatte vorhin als wir hier reinkam einer
jungen ukrainischen abgeordneten
svitlana seinen job versprochen dass sie
eine frage stellen kann und da hinten
ist sie auch blies
vielen dank herr botschafter ischinger
werte frau bundeskanzlerin ich möchte
ihnen zunächst danken dafür was sie ganz
persönlich tun im kampf gegen viele der
herausforderungen von denen wir heute
sprechen diesem raum
meine frage geht nun um etwas was sie
schon angesprochen haben in ihrer rede
und ich spreche von dem thema north
stream 2 in einem der wirtschaftszeitung
wurde gesagt nord stream 2 macht ukraine
polen und die baltischen staaten weniger
sicher sie untergräbt die
energiesicherheit der eu und gibt
russland bessere möglichkeiten
westeuropa zu bedrohen und seht
uneinigkeit unter den nato partnern
so wurde das in dem artikel beschrieben
und der titel war nord stream 2 ist eine
falle und deutschland ist in die falle
getappt das war der titel meine frage
frau bundeskanzlerin sind sie nicht der
meinung dass nord stream 2
diese rolle spielt die rolle der kleinen
grünen männchen in hinsicht auf die
energieversorgung vielen dank
ja danke schön für diese frage weil ich
weiß dass das auch die menschen nicht
nur in der ukraine sondern auch anderswo
umtreibt ist auch in deutschland eine
große kontroverse ist und jetzt sage ich
mal dazu folgendes oder ich habe
versucht schon ein bisschen darauf zu
antworten
die ukraine muss transit land bleiben
die anderen gasleitungen ja mal zum
beispiel durch polen und weißrussland
werden ja auch nicht dadurch
abgeschaltet und wir haben schon nord
stream 1&1 hat auch nicht dazu geführt
dass jetzt die dinge vollkommen gegen
die ukraine gelaufen sind außerdem haben
wir parallel darauf wird eigentlich sehr
wenig geachtet extreme eins und zwei
auch nochmal mit zweimal 55 milliarden
kubikmetern gas kapazität die auch
wiederum in den süden europas kommen
können und deshalb glaube ich und
deshalb haben wir uns ja auch diesen
kompromiss zugewandt ist es richtig und
wichtig dass europa natürlich in
gewisser weise die hoheit über seine
gasversorgung und die diversifizierung
dieser gasversorgung behält das ist
schon nicht nur wirtschaftlich sondern
auch politisch und dass deshalb das
dritte energiebinnenmarktpaket das ja
auf europäischem boden das unbundling
erfordert erzwingt das heißt es darf
niemals der röhren eigentümer auch der
gas eigentümer sein das ist jetzt
ausgeweitet auf die territorialgewässer
durch den kompromiss richtlinie dass wir
dadurch steuerungsmöglichkeiten haben
wir hatten zum beispiel den weiter
leiter von norddeutschland nach dem
süden opal heißt diese gaspipeline die
ist zeitweise gar nicht in ihrem volumen
ganz ausgenutzt worden durch nord stream
1 weil wir die schwierigkeiten mit der
ukraine hatten und das haben wir dann
durchaus auch dazu genutzt zu sagen
leute wir müssen jetzt in den
politischen prozessen ein bisschen
vorankommen ich glaube also wir haben
steuerungsinstrumente und an unsere
amerikanischen kollegen möchte ich
folgendes sagen
ich meine wir haben seit drei jahren
vielleicht die erwartete oder die
erlaubnis dass amerika
erdgas als lng exportiert die
vergangenen 67 jahre seit der gründung
der bundesrepublik deutschland war kein
amerikanisches erdgas zur verfügung wir
hatten uns in richtung golfregion
umgeguckt wir haben natürlich unsere
europäischen quellen gehabt norwegen usw
und natürlich werden wir es wenn es auch
sozusagen bezahlbar und vernünftig ist
und alles spricht dafür dass lng auch
mit einem preis auf den markt treten
wird der vielleicht sogar bestimmt sein
wird für den gesamten zukünftigen
gasmarkt alles spricht dafür dass der
natürlich auch auf amerikanisches gas
kaufen es überhaupt gar keine frage aber
bewusst politisch russland
auszuschließen
das halte ich auch für falsch das ist
signal halte ich strategisch für uns für
falsch ich habe ihnen gesagt im 2000
jahre 2011 haben hier alle gestanden und
haben gesagt ein neuer meilenstein im
jahr 2014 war alles dahin
im jahre 2009 10 sieht es schlecht aus
aber wir müssen weiter daran arbeiten
geostrategisch kann europa kein
interesse daran haben alle beziehungen
nach russland zu kommen
die kappen und deshalb mache ich eine
politik mache ich eine politik aber die
die ist immer wieder gegenstand von
diskussionen das verstehe ich doch auch
mache ich eine politik bei der
einerseits härte da ist das kann glaube
ich präsident poroschenko bestätigen und
auf der anderen seite ist aber mich auch
etwas verzweifelt wegen ostring zwei das
weiß ich damit müssen wir auch leben und
deshalb muss ich mich umso mehr dafür
einsetzen dass die ukraine gas
transitland bleibt
frau bundeskanzler demnächst es gibt
keine möchte sicherheitskonferenz bei
der nicht unser alter freund françois
heißt die gelegenheit bekommt eine frage
zu stellen
vielen dank wolfgang frau
bundeskanzlerin zunächst einmal vielen
dank für eine hervorragende rede ich
glaube da spreche ich im namen aller das
ist eine der besten reden die ich jemals
gehört habe
meine frage ist folgendermaßen sie sind
ja die der erfahrenste langjährige der
staats- und regierungschefs in der
europäischen union
das ist ja ganz außergewöhnlich wenn
sich aus ihrer erfahrung heraus all
diese jahre ansehen was würden sie sagen
was ist die größte errungenschaft
deutschlands über diese jahre hinweg und
was ist ihrer meinung nach der größte
grund bedauern zu hart empfinden über
diese zeit ja also ich würde sagen
in anlehnung an ihre frage sag ich mal
eine sache die ich gut finde bei
deutschland und eine die ich nicht so
gut findet und ich fange mit der nicht
so gut an wir brauchen oft sehr sehr
lange wir uns gerade bei
außenpolitischen arrangement für
irgendetwas entscheiden und das gibt
immer viele viele innere kämpfe und
andere sind schon längst dabei und so
und das ist manchmal schon hinderlich
und auch im blick auf das was ich
gesprochen aber was mir im augenblick
sehr große sorgen macht dass es eben
auch die uns in frage unserer
rüstungsexportpolitik ich sage das ganz
offen
wir haben aus unserer geschichte gute
gründe sehr strenge
rüstungsexportrichtlinien zu haben
aber wir haben genauso gute gründe in
der verteidigungs gemeinschaften auch
gemeinsam aufzutreten und gerade wenn
wir eine europäische einigkeit haben
wollen gemeinsame kampfflugzeuge
gemeinsamen panzer entwickeln wollen
dann wird es nicht anders gehen als dass
wir uns auch auf gemeinsame
rüstungsexportrichtlinien schrittweise
hin bewegen und da ist deutschland
vielleicht aus der sicht vieler oft ein
zu langsamer partner oder sagen es ist
so
gut ist dass wenn wir einmal wo sind
bleiben wir auch also afghanistan sind
hier vorbildlich 18 jahre die da sind
schon viele raus und rein gegangen
wir sind für die vielen kleinen länder
22 nationen die mit uns dort sind ein
stabilitätsanker und wir haben dann
nicht einfach wieder ab deshalb tun wir
schnell vielleicht manchmal auch so
schwer irgendwo hinzugehen weil wir
denken da bleibt man ewig weil die
konflikte ja auch nicht so schnell
gelöst werden also in meiner amtszeit
musste deutschland sehr viel stärker
sich einbringen und das ist auch richtig
so weil befüllbar das argument ihr habt
eine geschichtliche historische
besonderheit und deshalb müsst ihr euch
militärisch nicht so engagieren nicht
mehr zählt das wird inzwischen als
bequemlichkeit ausgelegt aber nicht als
etwas wo man sagt aha da seid ihr aber
besonders an eure geschichte gebunden
und weil wir ich war bei der beerdigung
von george bush senior weil wir durch
ihn gerne hier noch einmal daran
erinnern an den großen präsidenten der
damals eben dafür sorge getragen hat
dass die deutsche einheit gelingen
konnte im gemeinsamkeit mit den
alliierten und die verpflichtung heißt
für uns heute verantwortung übernehmen
und wir sind wir bei unseren schatten
gesprungen das kann von außen vielleicht
keiner verstehen aber zum beispiel als
wir waffen an die peschmerga im irak
geliefert habe das ist krass gegen alle
unsere richtlinien
aber wir haben es gemacht weil wir
gesagt haben wir können der vernichtung
des jemenitischen volkes nicht zuschauen
und solche solche verantwortung werden
wir immer weiter hinein dax
ich glaube wir haben noch zeit für eine
oder zwei fragen da drüben hat sich ihr
biograf cornelius gemeldet denen wir
jetzt als erster dran biografie sagt
wenn ich einmal sehen dann bleiben wir
auch ich dachte sie sprechen von sich
meine frage geht eigentlich nicht
verstanden ist auch nicht wichtig meine
meine frage zielt auf europa ab das ist
ein gebiet die europäische union die sie
in der regel wirklich nicht in der tiefe
erwähnt haben deswegen möchte ich
nachhaken
wir erleben im moment
auflösungserscheinungen in der
europäischen union wir sehen den praxis
wir haben große innenpolitische
zerfallserscheinungen was das
parteiensystem betrifft in frankreich
und spanien in italien große
verschiebung der französische präsident
hat sie vor zwei jahren sozusagen
herausgefordert eine große initiative zu
machen einen großen aufschlag zu geben
hin zu einer goldgrube zu unternehmen
wie das auf englisch ausgedrückt werden
könnte
die kritik ist sie reagiert darauf nicht
es gibt puzzleteile und sie fügen sie
zusammen und sie werden jetzt mir
wahrscheinlich antworten wir haben sie
ja den neuen led vertrag und wir haben
uns hier und dort auf dinge geeinigt was
ist bitte ihre botschaft hinzu
europawahl was diese gemeinschaft
zusammenhält und was sie als grosses
nächstes ziel sich vornehmen sollen mal
schön wenn der frage auch schon die
antwort und damit diesen teil der
antwort nicht möchte aber ich glaube ich
bin trotzdem frei in der antwort ja
europa ist in großen schwierigkeiten
aus meiner sicht hat das etwas zu tun
mit unserer
nicht ausreichende innovationsfähigkeit
und unseren wirtschaftlichen
schwierigkeiten wo genau das was
weltweit passiert auch in europa
passieren kann einer gegen den anderen
und da müssen wir jetzt zusammen
arbeiten und ich glaube was deutschland
in frankreich zum beispiel im blick auf
künstliche intelligenz und alle fragen
die im zusammenhang mit der
digitalisierung stehen unternommen haben
ist nicht zu unterschätzen auch wenn man
die ergebnisse noch nie sieht zweitens
europa hat gegner und die hybride
kriegsführung seitens russland ist
täglich zu spüren in jedem der
europäischen länder angegriffen werden
immer die ökonomisch schwächsten als
erstes und das was wir da sehen sind
große große herausforderung und wenn wir
nicht verstehen dass das im grunde gegen
uns alle geht sondern immer denken der
eine hat gerade ein problem und der
andere hat ein problem bleibt eines
tages sehen dass wir alle probleme haben
und diese hybride kriegsführung im
internet ist sehr schwer zu erkennen
weil sie plötzlich bewegungen haben von
denen sie gedacht haben dass sie nie
auftreten die immer ansätzen an einem
manko die einen prozess noch in
deutschland protestieren jetzt die
kinder für klimaschutz was ist ein
wirklich wichtiges anliegen aber dass
plötzlich alle deutschen kinder nach
jahren ohne jede sozusagen äußeren
einfluss auf die idee kommen dass man
diesen prozess machen muss das kann man
sich auch nicht vorstellen also
kampagnen können heute über das internet
viel leichter gemacht werden und so
haben wir andere kampagnen ich will da
jetzt nicht weiter ins detail gehen und
wir haben auch andere gruppen
ich will da durchaus die spenden nicht
dass man sagt sie redet drum herum die
nicht
die nicht die das europäische modell im
sinn haben und dagegen müssen wir uns
gemeinsam wehren und das haben wir noch
können wir noch nicht ausreichend genug
zweitens die sorbonne rede und die
mangelnde antwort deutschlands
cornelius ich sage ihnen wir haben in
vielen fragen uns besiegt sonst eher
auch der aachener vertrag gar nicht
zustande gekommen aber deutschland und
frankreich alleine sind auch nicht
europa wenn ich eine euro konzeption
habe und die niederlande machen nicht
mit und finnland macht nicht mit und die
anderen sagen es ist zu wenig das ist
auch in europa es muss etwas gemeinsames
dabei rauskommen wenn deutschland und
frankreich irgendein
das gemeinsam machen und anschließend
sagen 20 ländern europas machen wir aber
nicht mit und sagen sie auch wir haben
versagt das heißt wir müssen auch alle
mitnehmen und der dritte punkt ist wir
haben angesichts des austritt
großbritanniens aus der europäischen
union ist uns sehr stark fokussiert und
das sichtbarste beispiel ist für mich
die gemeinsame verteidigungspolitik bis
hin zu einer europäischen armee
vielleicht eines tages das war früher
undenkbar
und da müssen wir jetzt die nächsten
schritte auch gehen und ich finde das
ist ein ziemlich großes projekt und wenn
im aachener vertrag steht deutschland
und frankreich verpflichten sich
gegenseitig bei jeder herausforderung
füreinander einzustehen zusätzlich zu
dem was wir an der naht rische gemacht
haben dann ist das kein pappenstiel
sondern dann ist das eine große sache
die wir jetzt im täglichen leben auch
beweisen müssen also wir müssen kämpfen
für dieses europa für den
multilateralismus und gegen aldi dem
glauben sie können zu hause die probleme
gegen den anderen am besten lösen das
ist aber nicht ganz einfach
[Applaus]
meine damen und herren liebe freunde ich
weiß sie haben noch sehr viele fragen
aber leider geht uns die zeit aus und
die frau bundeskanzlerin hat auch noch
andere termine
auch mit teilweise mit teilnehmern hier
ich möchte diese gelegenheit ergreifen
der frau bundeskanzlerin zu danken
jetzt machen wir eine 20-minütige
kaffeepause kleine runde airports haben
bevor wir ja auch